It was super frustrating.
I went with my mom to the most storied cathedrals to Western
medicine.
And in every instance I experienced what I've come to call diagnose and
adios. And I have a lot of respect for medicine. In fact,
when I started college, I wanted to be a doctor.
I was pre-med for the first few years,
but truly in,
in none of those doctor's offices was diet or lifestyle ever really brought up.
I'm Dave Rubin.
And this is the Rubin report as always guys click that little subscribe button
on YouTube. So you might just might see our videos. Now,
joining me today is a New York times bestselling author of genius foods
and the author of the new book, the genius life, max Luger here.
Welcome back to the Rubin report. So good to be here.
Thank you for having me New York times, best selling author.
Where are you in New York times,
best selling author last time you were about to become okay.
About to become, I didn't know it at the time.
I had no idea how well genius foods would ultimately do, but, um,
I'm super grateful,
humble that it's reached big audience is now published in eight languages around
the world. It's super cool. I was in Columbia.
I was in Bogota and I had like a line of Spanish speaking fans lined up to get
their book signed and, you know, we could barely communicate,
but it was just so, so gratifying to see that, you know.
How does it change one's life to become a New York times bestselling author? Um,
you know,
I think he doesn't really like level up the amount of stuff that you suddenly
get. Cause people are like, Oh,
this guy actually does know what he's talking about.
It's not just a book about food.
It's a credential. Um, and you know, I'm, I'm very, uh,
I never misrepresent myself. I mean, I'm, uh, I write about health and science,
but I do it not from, uh, not with having a background in academia or medicine.
I'm just a, I'm passionately curious. And I it's a topic, you know,
that I think is the most important topic there is. Uh,
but the fact that the book continues to be it, wasn't just sort of a,
there's this metaphor in, in book sales, you know, when you,
when you launch a book it's like throwing up,
you could be throwing up either a feather or a brick and like a feather is what
you want to happen because the feather, it goes up and then it kind of floats,
uh,
the brick just ends up coming right down to the fact that genius foods has kind
of just stayed up, you know, and it continues to, to,
to sell well, to me as a Testament, to the quality of the work,
really ultimately, and as a writer,
that's the best form of flattery that you can, that you can get, you know, that,
that your writing is embraced and that it continues to do well. So yeah,
I'm super thrilled. It's given me the opportunity to write, um, this book,
the genius life I have since launched my own podcast,
which is also called the genius life.
So it's allowed me to get to do what I love to do. Full-time and,
and as you know, it's a great thing to be, you know,
to work for yourself and to, to be, um, driven on your own steam. Yeah.
It's a pretty sweet thing. And you're building a studio in your apartment,
which I know a little something about that.
So we could do a separate show on that, but, uh,
for people that didn't see our first interview, we'll,
we'll link to it in this so they can jump back. Um,
but one of the things I find most interesting about you and you and I now go
back like six, seven years. So before you wrote genius foods, um,
your story on how you came to kind of care about this stuff is,
well, it's deeply personal, but it's also pretty fascinating actually.
Could you do like a quick recap on that?
Absolutely. Yeah. I started as a journalist.
I was a generalist working for Al Gore's current TV, which was not a, my role.
There was not as a, um, uh, a flag bearer of his political,
you know, ideas and environmental ideas. I was,
I got the job right out of college and I got to cover stories that were
important to me. And they ranged from health and technology to, um,
politics occasionally. But when I left that job after six years,
I started spending more and more time in New York city,
which is where I'm from around my mother. And I'm first born child,
very close to my mom.
She started at the age of 58 to display the earliest symptoms of dementia.
And she had a very strange confluence of symptoms.
She had symptoms that were more indicative of a memory disorder,
and then she had movement symptoms,
which would indicate a more Parkinsonian complex, like Parkinson's disease.
And it was something that, um, was traumatic to, to witness.
Uh, you know, when we got the initial diagnosis.
Were you literally the first person that noticed anything or was she noticing
that something was going on?
She knows she was, she started to complain of brain fog memory problems, but,
uh, we didn't have the vernacular in my family.
We had no prior family history of any kind of neurodegenerative disease.
And interestingly, my mom's mom, my maternal grandmother, um,
was she lived to 96 and she was cognitively sharp until the end. Wow.
So she was, my, my grandmother was not demented.
And so the idea that my grandma's my daughter,
my mom could somehow be succumbing to this condition that I think most people
assume to be an old person's disease.
It just didn't compute didn't make any sense. Yeah.
And so when my mom was initially prescribed those, you know,
the drugs for Alzheimer's disease and Parkinson's disease,
that was the first time in my life I'd ever had a panic attack. You know,
I'm a pretty chill guy, but, uh, it was,
I was alone in the hotel room in Cleveland,
Ohio Googling the drug prescriptions,
which I think anybody would do in that position.
And the severity of the situation really dawned on me at that moment.
And from that point on,
I decided to dedicate all of my free time to
investigating why this would have happened to my mom,
what could be done to help or what could be done to prevent it from happening to
myself. And that began about eight years ago.
And, um, that was a struggle, obviously,
you know,
watching my mom descend and become more and more handicapped by the disease.
And that's what motivated me to write, uh,
genius foods and to do all the work that I've, you know, that I, that I put out.
Um,
and what occurred after genius foods came out was,
uh, I mean, equally surprising, um, and equally heartbreaking.
I was in the middle of writing this book when my mom turned yellow.
And you could, I mean, usually if you turn yellow, uh, you know,
it's either going to be jaundice or you've eaten too much, beta carotene,
you've eaten too many carrots. Yeah. Um, but what happens, uh, with jaundice,
the whites of your eyes actually become yellow.
That's kind of what distinguishes it from just, you know, eating,
eating too many sweet potatoes.
And my family rushed her to the emergency room.
They did an MRI of her abdomen and what they discovered was not a gallstone,
which is typically what, you know,
it'll cause a blockage in the bile duct cause bilirubin,
which is a pigment to back up into your blood. What they found was much worse.
It was a tumor on the head of her pancreas. And, uh,
she was diagnosed with pancreatic cancer in 90% of the time when pancreatic
cancer is diagnosed,
it's already progressed and it was three months and she was, you know,
it was the most, it was barbaric and brutal. And, uh, and,
and that's what she ultimately passed from.
But the fact that my mom had these two freak health conditions,
two of the most feared conditions, uh, known to humanity, um,
it motivates me every day to, to learn more,
to teach more and to just stay open and curious and always be willing to
challenge my assumptions and my beliefs about what it means to be healthy in the
21st century.
Yeah. Well, that's why I think your story is so cool. I mean, just like, you're,
you're a good guy, but you've also like, even when I, you know,
follow you on Instagram and you do a lot of like, you know, don't eat this,
eat this kind of stuff. It's a very, it's very human.
You're not like beating people over the head with all this.
And I want to get to some of those, uh,
techniques and little tricks that you use to make things a little bit healthier.
Um, but when your,
when your mom got diagnosed and then subsequently when you did all of the things
that you tried to do over the course of that time, um,
was anyone else talking about food or was it all just like,
this is what you take. This is what you take, we'll up it here. If this happens,
you do this, like, was there any, like eat more avocado? No.
Oh, it was super frustrating.
I went with my mom to the most storied cathedrals to Western
medicine.
And in every instance I experienced what I've come to call diagnose and
adios. And I have a lot of respect for medicine. In fact,
when I started college, I wanted to be a doctor.
I was pre-med for the first few years,
but truly in,
in none of those doctor's offices was diet or lifestyle ever really brought up.
And the contrast between what I was experiencing in the,
in the clinician's offices with my mom and what I started to discover in the
medical literature,
there was just this big Valley in between the dearth of information and the,
and the despair that I was seeing there with my mom and the optimism that I was
reading about, um, in the, in the medical literature.
And ultimately what I did was I realized that I had met, uh, media credentials,
and I started to reach out to scientists and who were the authors of the papers
that I was reading. And they echoed that, that sentiment of optimism.
And yet at the point of care with my mom,
what I experienced was was anything but optimistic.
So I really had to take it upon myself. And I think when you're a patient,
my mom was scared. She was confused.
She didn't have a framework for understanding health or science or anything like
that. I did because I had a, I had had a lifelong passion for the topic. Um,
but, but really, I think there are a lot of people in our,
in her shoes that are met with the same kind of, um, I don't know,
like a hopelessness and yeah, you're right. I mean, what they, what,
what every doctor would ultimately do would titrate up the dose of a medication
that she was already on, throw something new into the mix.
And by the time my mom passed, she was on 10 different pharmaceuticals.
I'm not even being hyperbolic.
And there's just no way that a physician can have, you know,
any idea of how each of those pills are interacting with one another in a
body that's growing increasingly frail.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.